it's good
i'll just get the map up here so i don't
uh don't miss an entrance
uh we got seven more miles to go i
thought i'd come back on and show you
give you my critique of hda2
um so first off
the first thing you notice is look at
this uh
you don't see it right now but when the
cars get next to me you can see them
appear on the radar uh you can see that
the radar is tracking two lead cars
uh which is all pretty cool
their lateral policy is good but it
ping-pongs
and there's that
um and it gives me alerts
you can see it can do automatic lane
changes though i'm not sure we're gonna
see if it'll ever actually make the lane
change without
i think i have to nudge
or keep my hands on the wheel let's see
if it'll do it
no it won't
it won't it canceled it okay so they
require a nudge as well
um
yeah a tiny bit of ping pong but overall
this system is very usable like this
system well outperforms open pilot uh in
some of the lower end open pilot cars on
the highway
uh so congratulations kia i mean it's
good is it running open pilot
no no they uh
the sonata wasn't really good like the
sonata one wasn't really usable
uh on anything except for straights but
they they finally did a good job with
this one uh who knows and like you know
your thing is you're never gonna know
what version you're running
uh
the car is
the car itself is is it's not as noise
dead thing as the sonata i actually
don't like this car as much as the
sonata
um
but the car itself is dead silent i can
hear all the road outside
the navigation experience was decent to
use yo if you're in the market for a car
and you like this you know you're
looking for the fan right here let's do
one of their lane changes
so this is their lane change
it's it's good it's it's it's blinker
and nudge the same as open pilot
you can see that the radar is tracking
multiple leads in different lanes
it's just displaying it which is kind of
cool
uh
they claimed that the acc is using uh
it's using quote unquote ai so i wonder
what that actually means
let's get back over here give it a nudge
pretty good
the road is more noticeable because
there's no engine noise so yeah it might
not actually be deadened uh but i i
don't know
i prefer the sonata as a car
but uh
the
this is the first other than supercruise
this is the first uh
autopilot system i'm impressed with
i mean this an autopilot aside from
supercruise and autopilot this is this
is top tier
um i like that it still has instant
torque even at highway speeds
see it's too close to that truck
the lateral policy in subtle ways is not
as good as open pilots
but
overall
pretty impressive
you can see like look there's a little
bit of ping pong look you can see it on
the wheel and i'll turn the light on
now it's doing a turn it doesn't seem to
ping pong in the turns
this is this is this is this turn is
great
uh
first impressions phenomenal car
uh you know if you guys are hanging out
for the stream let's take it on the 163
and we'll try it on an actually
difficult road let's do it automatically
and change here
it feels the system feels very intuitive
like i i almost i forget
that this is
okay make the second oh that's not good
okay that ui was confusing oh i don't
know what it's doing now
okay you have to wait for the you have
to wait for the steering wheel to turn
green
uh once the steering wheel is green up
there it means it's like locked on
uh
it's really easy to forget that this car
isn't open pilot
[Music]
but now let's see if it can do anything
difficult
all right all right i'll keep my hands
on the wheel they have some attentioning
when i go like this
it says my attention level is high i
think it's just based on
timers
uh i don't think it does any driver
monitoring of any sorts
it lets you keep your hands off the
wheel for a surprisingly long amount of
time
see so i'll torque the wheel now
and now i'll let it go
i also like that it says it says on the
the hud
uh
hda nav so i wonder if it's at all
integrated with the nav like will it
take an exit
uh so you guys see the timer for how
long i've had my hands off the wheel
uh kia i'm trusting uh your light i'm
trusting my life with your torque limits
here don't don't make shitty torque
limits
i don't think they did
yeah
very very usable all right so this is
the first like real turn let's see
okay
so it gave me an alert to put my hand on
the wheel but overall great
wow the thing is like this isn't
conveyed to consumers at all
like like like ford does all this stuff
about blues cruise and i heard it's
actually terrible and then no one talks
about this system which is good
tiny amount of ping pong on
straightaways but that's it
i mean this makes me think that we
really like red lights and stop signs
this comes to open pilot is going to be
the the feature that crushes it i mean
this is okay this is also you know it's
too clear lane highway driving so i
shouldn't i shouldn't hype it up too
much
uh but
you know considering most of the
manufacturers can't even get two two
highway lines matching
two highway lines good
uh
i'm very impressed by this
all right we're gonna we're gonna go
somewhere tricky uh in a bit this this
road turns into a tricky one does it
feel like it's driving lane full or
laneless it feels
completely lane fall it feels like it's
not doing anything with the radar
information
um
i mean i don't know like i i certainly
prefer the laneless policy auto proud to
the landfill policy because it like
moves a little for cars
uh so no it feel it feels landfall it's
definitely using lanes we know it's
using the lanes
uh
but
you know it's not just about lane fall
like the entry and exit from the turns
is competent and this is something that
took us a while to get good in open
pilot like we it would it's not
undercutting or or overshooting turns
which
almost all the stock systems do
the sweetest sensors so we have four
corner radars
we have a forward-facing radar
and we have a camera module which i
think is just one camera
it has ultrasonics but those are
connected to the parking ecu
um the two rear radars are kept on kind
of a legacy system so i actually have a
theory that
so you'll see like when the car comes up
next to me i actually think that's being
captured on the front radar and the back
raiders are still just doing blind spot
monitoring but i hope i'm wrong about
that
um you see you see how that that red
shows up yeah okay yeah you see the car
it's pretty good right
and it looks like the autopilot display
uh let's see if it'll follow my nav
i don't think i have any nav
instructions coming up soon
uh but yeah i mean like it is on this on
this clearly marked highway uh it is
very easy to think that open pile is
driving right now
so yeah props to uh
props to kia for for for building
something decent
all right probably died
um who has the best display ui tesla's
is nice i don't know i like cars that
actually shows the camera though
uh yeah yeah we have that we have the
blind spot infotainment it'll do that if
that's what you mean
uh how does the driver monitoring work
there's no driving motor in this car
i wish
you know okay
uh it will eventually on sharp turns
it's related to the curvature of the
road
it comes up with things saying uh you
gotta take over or you gotta put your
hands on the wheel and then i think it's
torque based i don't think there's
sensors
i tried just putting my hand and didn't
do anything
bacon in support of chinese cars i don't
know what that means
stream
uh all right well i really want to
you want to stick with me guys till we
get to the other side of the i8 and
we're going to take this thing on the
163 and see what it can really do
um overall this is just like bare bare
levels of competency
uh you know it's just the fact that the
fact that no manufacturer
aside from
autopilot super cruise and now this one
have gotten
like moderate highway turns to work
it's just
a
wild
thing
but some other thing um super cruise
couldn't do the 163 because i don't
think their roll compensation was good i
don't think this car has ota updates
though i might be wrong like i don't
really know it certainly doesn't
advertise it anywhere
um
what's in the next one after this update
you can read uh we got a blog post
coming out tomorrow i think the release
goes live tomorrow all right here sorry
we got some more serious turns now it's
telling me to keep my hands on the
steering wheel though i'm curious what
it does if i don't we can try letting
the driver monitoring time out
um their longitudinal policy the
longitudinal policy in this car is
better than our longitudinal policy
auto pilots is better as well
but this is
going to change with m10 longitudinal
um i'm still confident open pilot has
the best lateral policy in the world
uh yeah obama's gonna support canadian
for this car
no i'm not getting on i8 staying right
here in this lane okay you guys ready
for the test
this is gonna be the real test we're
gonna see what it can do
keeping my hand on the wheel but loosely
it's a little too far to the right in
that turn
um
[Music]
late entry into that turn slightly
good cutting behavior
oh it's beeping at me
this is good so far
[Music]
this is good so far
okay let's say
[Music]
cool
all right
also you can't see but it's doing a it's
doing like an augmented display i think
you can see it through the hud on that
car which is pretty cool okay speed up
for the turn
uh cut and cut in cut in
nope nope nope
okay
spider all right all right
i like it it's one button to re-engage
okay
so
[Music]
good
and the yeah it's very good it's very
does it disengage on gas no it doesn't
just engage in gas i can gas right now
and it doesn't disengage
uh cool guys that ends my review of hda2
uh i gotta drive on the streets
so i gotta leave you
but uh yeah this is a great car uh the
system's great
it's
it's
at least on highways
it's uh similar in quality autopilot
depending on the car
which makes me think